I mean I think in brains in other
species is also
an area of study for for some people and
the differences with with our brain
capacities uh the you know the
difference we have this tendency of
thinking that there's a huge gap but I'm
not convinced by that actually and the
main reason I'm not convinced by by that
is that
I think of evolution again and if if we
trust what evolution is about there
should be a Continuum you mentioned the
word Continuum so I expect that there
are there is a Continuum and I I'm not I
would expect I wouldn't wouldn't be
surprised if we we start eventually
discovering that some species are maybe
leaving patterns and using that to to
pass knowledge over so what one of the
other key characteristics of our human
intelligence is we we have this capacity
to Archive knowledge and pass it on and